Transcription: Jules Daunay
Relecteur: eric vautier
Je m’appelle Hakim Harezski,
je suis né le premier jour
du printemps 1983, en Kabylie.
Je suis l'aîné d'une famille
de quatre enfants.
Comme tous les jeunes de mon âge,
je vais à l'école.
Je pratique beaucoup de sport
En sport individuel, je suis passionné
par les arts martiaux.
Et en sport collectif,
j’adore le football.
Je suis jeune et
j’ai des rêves plein la tête
dans mes montagnes qui me sont si chères.
Azul fellawen.
Azul qui veut dire
« Salut » en kabyle.
Dans la vie de tous les jours,
je parle kabyle.
D'ailleurs, depuis ma naissance,
je ne parle que kabyle.
En revanche, à l’âge de six ans,
il faudra parler une autre langue.
Il faudra étudier en arabe.
On est petit, on ne comprend pas tout,
mais on suit quand même.
Lorsqu’on grandit,
on se pose la question :
« Bon sang, pourquoi je n’ai pas le droit
d’étudier dans ma langue maternelle
et de parler kabyle ?
Ni de connaître mes vraies origines,
mon histoire, ma culture ?
Pourquoi je n’ai pas le droit
de vivre libre dans mon pays ? »
Étudiant au lycée, plus tard,
avec mes camarades,
on sort manifester dans la rue,
manifester pacifiquement.
Filles et garçons mélangés.
Petits et grands.
On manifestait contre cette oppression
et cette injustice sociale,
contre la falsification
et la confiscation de notre histoire,
de nos origines, notre culture.
On manifestait tout simplement
contre toutes les injustices
qu’il y avait en Algérie.
En face de nous, des gendarmes,
armés d’armes d’assaut.
On fait une minute de silence
et les gendarmes provoquent.
Ils nous tirent dessus avec des bombes
lacrymogènes, des rafales à blanc.
La manifestation dégénère.
Tout le monde court partout,
les cris, les larmes.
On jette des cailloux
et ils ripostent avec des bombes
lacrymogènes et des rafales à blanc.
Pendant un petit moment,
je me suis demandé
s’ils allaient vraiment nous tirer dessus.
On était des jeunes.
OK, on était révolté par les injustices.
On était révolté par ce qui se passait
là-bas, mais on n’était pas dangereux
et surtout, on n’était pas armés.
Malheureusement, le pouvoir algérien
a ordonné qu’on nous tire dessus
avec des vraies balles,
des balles réelles.
Explosion et lumière blanche.
Impossible de vous dire
combien de temps dure ce moment.
Ce moment incroyable, cette douceur,
cette légèreté, en fait, cette lumière
tellement attirante, tellement rassurante,
tellement tellement blanche.
Ce moment de légèreté.
J'avais l'impression de flotter,
de voler, de nager.
Les mouvements, le temps, le souffle,
la vie, tout s'arrête.
Mort.
Non, cette horrible douleur.
Non, je ne suis pas mort, enfin je crois.
Presque à bout portant,
j’ai reçu deux balles de kalachnikov.
Une balle qui m’a traversée
la cheville droite
et une autre balle qui est venue
se loger dans ma tête.
La deuxième balle était
une balle explosive.
Vous avez bien entendu :
des balles explosives.
Des balles explosives contre
des jeunes qui manifestent,
contre des mains vides,
contre des yeux pleins de rêves
pleins de couleurs et pleins d’espoir.
La deuxième balle m’a atteint
au niveau du crâne.
Elle a explosé en plusieurs morceaux.
Elle m’a sectionné
les deux nerfs optiques.
Je venais tout simplement de perdre la vue
d’une manière cruelle,
sauvage et définitive.
Je venais de perdre la vue à la vitesse
d’une balle de kalachnikov
tirée à moins de 30 mètres.
La dernière image de mon monde
de voyant sera à tout jamais
cet attroupement de gendarmes.
Ces gendarmes qui ont prêté serment
de nous défendre, de nous protéger,
les voilà aujourd’hui
qui dirigent leurs armes vers nous.
Ils tirent, ils tirent
pour tuer des enfants.
Ce 27 avril 2001 marquera
pour moi la fin d’une vie
et ce sera officiellement
le début de ce qu’on va appeler
le Printemps noir de Kabylie,
un massacre sanglant
orchestré, exécuté
par le pouvoir algérien en place.
Un massacre qui va malheureusement
rester à ce jour impuni
parce que la plupart des commanditaires
sont toujours en liberté.
Un massacre qui aura fait
plus de 127 morts
et plusieurs milliers
de blessés par balles.
Tout ça parce qu’on a osé dire,
on a osé contredire
et parce qu’on voulait vivre libres.
Tahar Djaout, un grand écrivain algérien,
disait : « Le silence, c’est la mort. »
« Le silence, c’est la mort,
et toi, si tu parles, tu meurs.
Si tu te tais, tu meurs.
Alors dis et meurs ! »
Moi, j’ai envie de dire,
mais j’ai aussi envie de vivre.
Des morts et des blessés partout
dans les rues de Kabylie.
Comme tous les blessés,
j’étais laissé pour mort.
J’ai été abandonné
dans un hall d’immeuble.
Les manifestants m’ont mis là
pour me protéger
parce que les gendarmes achevaient
leurs victimes, achevaient les blessés.
Et inconscient, bien évidemment,
je reprends conscience,
dans cette ambulance
qui allait me transporter
dans trois hôpitaux
différents la même nuit.
Jusqu’à cet hôpital
Mustapha Pacha à Alger,
où je vais rester cinq jours sans soins
parce que là encore,
le pouvoir algérien a ordonné
que l’on ne me soigne pas.
Je reprends conscience
dans cet hôpital, plusieurs fois.
Je reprends conscience dans une voiture,
dans un aéroport,
plusieurs fois dans un avion
et je reprends conscience enfin en France.
Tout le monde n’a pas eu
cette chance malheureusement.
Mon ami d’enfance Youssef,
qui lui avait reçu cinq balles,
cinq balles de kalachnikov
pour avoir osé manifester le même jour,
au même endroit, au même moment.
Il avait reçu cinq balles.
Il a pris également la direction
du ciel cette nuit-là
et il est parti briller
à tout jamais parmi les étoiles.
Il venait d'avoir 19 ans.
Le miracle, pour moi, c’était mon papa,
c’était ma belle-mère, mes oncles,
c’était toutes les personnes
qui les ont aidés, de près ou de loin,
à m’extraire des griffes de la mort.
Le miracle était la survie
durant ces cinq journées d’enfer
où je suis resté à l’hôpital sans soins.
Le miracle, enfin,
c’était ce vol Alger-Paris,
où j’ai voyagé assis comme tout le monde,
une cheville transpercée par une balle,
une balle explosive dans le crâne.
Le pire voyage de toute ma vie,
le plus douloureux, le plus périlleux,
le plus dangereux,
ce sera finalement le voyage
qui va me ramener à la vie.
Je suis en France, je suis vivant,
je vais vivre et être obligé de m’adapter.
Être obligé d’apprivoiser ce monde
dans lequel je me trouve désormais.
Un monde rythmé par le silence, les sons.
Un monde, au début, rythmé par le froid,
le chaos, les cris,
les larmes, les cauchemars.
En un mot, le chaos
dans un décor à l’unique couleur.
Depuis ce jour, bien évidemment,
beaucoup, beaucoup d’hôpitaux,
beaucoup de cliniques,
beaucoup d’interventions chirurgicales.
La rééducation aussi.
Pour pouvoir se relever.
Il est très, très dur
de revenir parmi les vivants
lorsque la mort vous a bercé
un moment dans ses bras.
Dans des moments comme celui-là,
on pense que tout est fini.
Et de toute façon, même si ce n'est
pas fini, tout sera impossible.
Et pourtant, je réussis
à revenir parmi les vivants.
Grâce encore une fois tout d’abord
à mon père, grâce à ma belle-mère.
Grâce à cette extraordinaire
prise en charge médicale,
depuis que je suis arrivé en France.
J'ai réussi à revenir parmi les vivants,
à rester debout, à me battre, à vivre.
Vivre au plus profond de moi, vivre en me
surpassant physiquement et moralement.
Vivre à condition d’apprivoiser
le noir total et irréversible.
La soif de vivre, la soif de résister
pour moi et pour les miens
ont fait de moi ce rescapé revenu
d’entre les mâchoires de la mort.
Ce moment-là marquera le début
de ma deuxième naissance.
2001.
Je suis mourant, aveugle
et en fauteuil roulant.
Depuis, j’ai beaucoup appris
grâce à autre chose que la vue.
Mon monde d’aujourd’hui,
je le fais et je le vis sans la vue,
mais pleinement avec mes autres sens
dans le toucher et l’écoute.
Je me suis intéressé
aux instruments de musique.
Je n’ai jamais touché d’instruments
de musique de ma vie de voyant.
Arrivé en France,
mon père me donne une guitare
pour passer le temps durant ces très,
très longues journées de convalescence
où je suis resté
pour la plupart de temps allongé
parce que je ne pouvais
pas me mettre debout.
Les journées où j’étais vraiment
en forme, j’arrivais à m’asseoir.
Sinon, c’était tout le temps allongé.
Cette guitare, j’ai appris
à faire plein de choses avec.
En fait, j’ai appris d’autant plus
que quelques années plus tard,
j’ai intégré l’Institut national
des jeunes aveugles à Paris.
Pour, à la base, finir ma rééducation,
apprendre le braille,
reprendre mes études.
C’est là où je prends
des cours de musique.
Je fais une formation musicale
et sept ans après avoir perdu la vue,
je deviens accordeur de piano.
Je fais deux albums
et je joue d’un instrument musical.
(Début de la musique)
(Fin de la musique)
En fait, ma mandole dans les mains,
mes doigts qui se baladent
sur ce morceau de bois
avec cette liberté de mouvement.
En fait, je la ramène partout,
je joue de la musique,
je compose des morceaux et c’est comme ça
que la musique a été ma première béquille
pour me remettre debout
après ce qui m’est arrivé.
Je relève le défi, justement,
de me remettre debout,
de remarcher tout d’abord.
Chose qui n’était pas facile, au début.
Et puis de reprendre le sport
malgré cette cheville
explosée par la balle.
Donc, je découvre le cécifoot
à l’Institut national
des jeunes aveugles, à Paris.
Au début, c’était très compliqué.
C’était très dur mais à force
d’entraînement, à force de ténacité,
j’intègre des clubs
de cécifoot tout d’abord.
Et en 2009, j'intègre l'équipe
de France de cécifoot.
Je deviens sportif de haut niveau,
champion d’Europe des nations.
Depuis ce jour, plusieurs fois
sur le podium européen :
je suis champion d’Europe, je suis
plusieurs fois vice-champion d’Europe
et je suis vice-champion
paralympique en 2012,
onze ans après avoir perdu la vue.
C'était un truc de dingue.
Aujourd'hui, je suis toujours membre
de l'équipe de France de cécifoot.
D’ailleurs, en pleine préparation
pour les prochains Jeux de Tokyo.
Je suis ambassadeur du sport,
je suis responsable développement
au sein de mon club.
Et je suis président du comité
départemental handisport
de Seine-Saint-Denis.
Le cécifoot, c’est
l’adaptation du football
pour les personnes non voyantes.
Vous vous demandez certainement
comment des personnes aveugles
peuvent faire du foot ?
Je vous ai dit tout à l’heure
que mon monde est désormais
rythmé par des sons et du silence.
C’est le mélange des deux
qui me permet aujourd’hui de pratiquer
pleinement ma passion sportive.
Un peu de silence chez les spectateurs,
de la communication entre les joueurs.
Un ballon sonore comme celui-ci
(Bruit de billes agitées)
C’est comme ça que j’arrive
à le repérer sur le terrain.
Je joue avec mes coéquipiers :
le toucher de balle et
les sources sonores qui nous entourent
nous aident à faire
ce qu’on veut du ballon
et de nos déplacements sur le terrain.
Vous savez, le sport, pour moi,
ça a été cette deuxième béquille,
justement, qui allait
me mettre définitivement debout
pour enclencher
ce processus de reconstruction.
Lorsqu’une vie bascule,
comme la mienne à l’époque,
il y a quelque chose
qui s’installe en nous :
c’est vouloir se relever, justement,
se fixer des objectifs
et tout faire pour aller les atteindre.
Pour moi, l’humilité,
le respect et la reconnaissance,
ce sont aussi des valeurs
qui se sont installées en moi.
Je pense que ces valeurs s’installent
lorsqu’on fait face à quelque chose
de puissant qui nous dépasse.
On fait avec, mais
on résiste et on se bat.
La confiance en soi, la confiance
en ses coéquipiers ou dans les autres,
le dépassement de soi,
ce sont là toutes les valeurs
qui ont fait mon éducation
et qui se sont forgées
depuis ces vingt ans où j’ai perdu la vue.
Ce sont aujourd'hui mes armes
pour affronter le quotidien.
Je ne pense pas qu’il existe
une potion magique pour la résilience.
Je pense que chacun peut avoir
sa propre recette.
Je pense aussi que la seule limite
dans cette vie, c'est la mort.
Tout le reste, tout le reste,
c'est des difficultés.
C’est des obstacles.
OK, des obstacles ou des difficultés
plus ou moins compliqués à surpasser.
Mais il faut savoir dans la vie -
Parfois, il faut accepter de contourner
un obstacle, une difficulté,
au lieu de s’acharner
à le dépasser sur le coup.
Si je vous raconte
aujourd’hui mon histoire,
si je vous ai raconté mon histoire,
c’est pour vous donner quelques éléments
qui ont marché pour moi
dans ce processus de résilience.
Ce qui a marché pour moi, c’était
cette volonté de faire quelque chose
de cette deuxième chance
que la vie venait de m’offrir.
Ce qui a marché, c’est cette volonté
de continuer le combat en mon nom
et au nom de tous ceux qui n’ont
pas eu la chance d’être sauvés,
comme moi j’ai pu l’être en 2001.
Ce qui a marché, c’est la forme,
mon combat, mes idées,
m’ont beaucoup aidé à me relever.
Clamer, toujours.
Ce devoir de clamer toujours
et jusqu’à aujourd’hui,
ce sera pour toujours.
Non à la vengeance,
mais plutôt la justice.
Ce qui a marché aussi,
c’est cette volonté d’essuyer les larmes
sur les visages des miens,
leur redonner espoir
et pourquoi pas, les rendre fiers
de ce que j'allais devenir.
Enfin, ce qui a marché,
c’est cette volonté
de redessiner un sourire sur le visage
de ma mère et mon père.
Un sourire qui a été effacé
par le pouvoir algérien,
comme il a été effacé
sur de nombreux visages
de nombreuses familles en Kabylie.
Pour faire tout ça,
pour prendre ma revanche
par rapport à ce qu’il s’est passé,
il fallait apprivoiser mon handicap,
faire de ce handicap une force,
un propulseur qui allait
me pousser vers l’avant
et non des chaînes qui allaient
me condamner à rester sur place.
Il fallait se réadapter.
Il fallait tout recommencer
quasiment à zéro
et il fallait tout simplement vivre.
Vivre peut-être dans un monde
qui est différent du vôtre,
un monde qui ne passe
plus par le regard,
un monde où il y a aujourd’hui entre nous
des battements de cœur,
des sons, du toucher
pour donner et recevoir.
Je pense que nous avons tous
une trajectoire, une histoire,
un monde différents.
Mettons tous nos mondes
à portée de main
pour qu’un jour nous ayons
quelque chose à offrir.
Peu importe le moment,
l’endroit ou la manière,
il y aura forcément quelqu’un
qui va en avoir besoin.
Avec les moyens qui
sont les miens aujourd’hui,
je fais mon monde à portée de main
et sans vous voir, je suis là devant vous
à vous offrir une petite
partie de celui-ci.
L’espoir, les amis, un cœur
plein d’espoir, plein de confiance,
voici un carburant qui maintient
quelqu’un debout et en vie.
Je finirai tout simplement
sur une touche très personnelle.
Mes valeurs, mon histoire,
mon combat, mon monde,
je continue à les transmettre.
Je continue à transmettre cette flamme
qui a certes vacillé
il y a de cela vingt ans.
Elle a vacillé, mais elle n’a pas
voulu s’éteindre.
Elle s’est au contraire
enflammée tel un brasier.
Elle a donné naissance à plusieurs flammes
qui, aujourd’hui, éclairent mon monde
telles des étoiles éclairant un ciel.
Mes étoiles, mes flammes
aujourd’hui s’appellent Yemma,
qui veut dire « Maman » en kabyle.
Ça s’appelle Vava, qui veut dire « Papa ».
Les flammes, ce sont
mon frère, mes sœurs,
mon épouse, mes amis.
Ce sont toutes les belles personnes
que j’ai pu rencontrer et qui m’ont aidé,
ne serait-ce que
d’une parole ou d’un geste.
Elle s’appelle depuis quelques mois -
depuis six mois exactement -
elle s’appelle Nélia, la plus belle,
la plus brillante, la plus étincelante.
Même si je ne la vois pas, je suis
l'heureux papa d'une petite merveille.
Nélia, je t’aime, ma fille.
Tanemmirte. Merci.
(Applaudissements)